and we're back right
ah post-election here to discuss why
many people got it wrong Alex Jones I am
so glad to be here
oh okay no we're trying to have a
post-election reasonable discussion get
the Yak get all on you fat whoa man I
thought we were here to have a
reasonable discussion no no where you
are reasonable the one yelling I haven't
even said anything
oh you're yelling you're unreasonable
what ya doing fat you know it's odd that
you're saying that to me when you're
sitting next to Cinque
it's glandular you know I have some
supplements here that might actually
help you that Bush [ __ ] trying to
sell supplements you always I was just
trying to help you always so supplements
knowing you gave Falls you always sewing
stuff please what
right now you're gonna plant I don't
know what you say the water makes the
frogs gate money okay let me go yeah
yeah you may be gay amphibious talk I'm
better than you I'm [ __ ] better than
you look I'm not gay but would it would
it be a problem if I was let's get back
to talking about President Trump that's
[ __ ] what is okay right the
Electoral College is [ __ ]
Donald Trump President Bush discussion
regardless of what you think about the
Electoral College
Donald Trump won the election that's the
reality right so this is the problem I'm
just sitting here and our stones going
on the show and so much of a [ __ ]
intellectual that I'm willing to
entertain
I have reasonable discussion and dude
[ __ ] you Frederator like Donald Trump is
Bush take another Margaret bacon grease
nap time for a bacon knows now mmm done
baking created my amazing grease nap no
please come on please happening can you
find it and I didn't
ah clear bacon grease on me
under and then you're gonna be charged
all your pop this may be a bad time I
may need time oh come back here
what oh yeah with a bad time you in
force what the hell am i involved with
here boy